hi i'm ed helms i'm janish meeting i'm
jesse lee
i'm michael grahas i'm dustin milligan
and here's what you should know about
rutherford falls
[Music]
rutherford falls is a show about a man
nathan
rutherford who lives in a town that
literally bears his last name because
his forefathers founded the town 400
years ago
anyone see the resemblance he takes a
lot of pride in the
town and in his family and maybe has
some blind spots
about his uh family lineage fun fact i'm
actually the last rutherford
to live here in rutherford falls his
best friend is a woman named regan who's
played by
janet schmeeding and she is a member of
the fictional
minnesota native tribe and the show is
really about their friendship
and about what happens in
their lives and in the town when there's
a
minor kerfuffle over a statue of
nathan's ancestor
rutherford falls is uh a creation
of mike shurer sierra teller or nellis
and myself
mike sure has done amazing stuff i
worked with him on the office of course
then he went on to
create parks and recreation and then
co-create
brooklyn nine-nine then the good place
and just
so much awesome television and sierra
has worked on brooklyn nine-nine and
superstore and
this show really fits into that kind of
zone of um
of an ensemble comedy ed helms also a
co-creator of this show
is probably one of the funniest people
i've ever met and also just one of the
nicest people in
in anywhere really when we started
rutherford falls we wanted to be smart
and
funny and i'm really i'm really proud of
the show we've made if you
love any or all of these shows i think
you're gonna feel
right at home on rutherford falls
i think the comedy in the show is uh
is is warm-hearted and earnest
sorry i get very sweaty when i'm
confident but also pretty biting at
times
you can't change history unless you got
a time machine and you don't because if
you did you'd go back in time and tell
yourself not to buy that blazer
yeah whoa whoa bobby coming in a little
hot there that's a sick burn though
it feels very grounded uh but in the
same way that
real life can get super silly and weird
sometimes
so does the show oh it's dehydrated
the tone of the show it's it's very
smart comedy in that
it weaves in authentic and unique
stories that people at home
anywhere can identify with i wish i
could count
the jokes per
minute they come fast
they hit hard you seem smart i'm
guessing lots of college
not ivy league but so close it drives
you
crazy northwestern everybody gets jokes
on the show
it's a great time go gamble away your
401ks
it's also a comedy about real
lives uh including real native
[Music]
lives this show
is one of the first of its kind it has
um a writing staff that is half native
half non-native i've worked in
television for 10 years
and i've never worked with another
native writer until their show
we had five native voices in the writers
room
and uh that creates a world
where native people who are
very funny in our daily lives are now
funny on screen the only native
artifacts and here are those bangs
we had native writers from all over the
country um so it's not any one kind of
point of view
i think that the the sort of influence
or the the sort of
mixing into the pot of of the native
point of view
really makes this show special and
different
[Music]
this show features a really diverse cast
starring michael gray eyes
this is all i can share janusz meeting
well i'm flattered and of course
in what world is vandalism funny we see
a diversity of
native characters and a diversity of
non-native characters
i remember one day i was on the set and
i was working with uh
jessie lee and i said to jesse our
communities communities of color
never really been featured in uh
mainstream shows
and i actually noticed that all the main
characters around nathan
were all actors of color and it really
struck me
i said this show is really going in
um uncharted territories um
with how it's mixing its casts and how
it's allowing
diverse voices to really really be heard
i'm proud of that
this show manages to somehow
handle kind of heavy subject matter but
does so
in a very light-hearted and heartwarming
way
that statue is core to who i am and if
it can just be picked up and tossed
around willy-nilly
with no regard for its historical
specificity
then literally who am i what you're
describing
is my entire life which i think is is a
reflection of the world right now we all
want to laugh
we all want to love we all want to live
love
laugh but there's also you know there's
some real stuff that we got to deal with
at the same time and i think uh what
better way than to
gather the family around the earth the
hearth where the tv is and watch
rutherford falls together so you can
live love laugh about things that affect
all of us
in a really important and significant
way did i say live love laugh enough
live love life live love laugh the most
important thing to know
check out rutherford falls streaming
april 22nd
on peacock okay everyone that concludes
our tour
and now our museum associate director
slash intern bobby yang
will hand out some complimentary
astronaut ice cream
you